ce soir on s'intéresse à l'apprentissage
et c'est avec lui si ses coups ni au
chapitre économie cette semaine gros
plots sur l'apprentissage il y a
quelques années cette voie et est
considérée comme formations de seconde
zone réservée aux mauvais élèves
aujourd'hui al'inverse elle est
présentée comme la solution miracle pour
lutter contre le chômage des jeunes
pourtant certaines branches de métiers
peine à recruter des apprentis ils sont
de moins en moins nombreux alors où est
le vrai du faux à orléans théophile mba
kesha les griefs ont enquêté du côté du
bâtiment
en 2015 la loire et salem a permis de
déverrouiller les rigidités qui paralyse
l apprentissage un apprenti couvreur il
n'avait pas le droit de monter sur un
toit ce qui paraît quand même une
aberration donc cette loi a permis de
faire ces avancées pour que le jeune
puisse travailler en toute sécurité et
en hauteur il y avait aussi
l'utilisation de machines dites
dangereuses entre guillemets c'est à
dire simplement une si donc ces
utilisations là ont été réglementés
aujourd'hui la nouvelle loi sur la
formation et l'apprentissage va encore
plus loin dans le sens des entreprises
nos entreprises du bâtiment sont à 39
heures par semaine et les apprentis
était limité à 35 heures jusqu'à hier et
ça c'est une avancée énorme qui va
faciliter aussi le recrutement de futurs
apprentis sur ce chantier
raphaël 10 et on va se faire la malle
être confronté à d'autres corps de
métiers épaulé par son maître
d'apprentissage en sortant de 3m on m'a
donné la possibilité de faire des stages
de découverte et j'ai fait de nombreux
corps de métiers jëf électricité j'ai
trouvé ma boîte et chez nikon a failli
aux loges et c'est vrai que j'ai fait un
stage je me suis d'accord ça intéressant
j'en ai fait un deuxième essai j'ai
vachement accroché sur le fait que c'est
un métier riche en technique après son
ca père raphaël va poursuivre sa
formation 1 bp brevet professionnel en
électricité il a de l'ambition et
l'avenir
plein de promesses quelques semaines de
formation et déjà des réflexes de
professionnels maëla bonjour vous êtes
apprentis en hôtellerie restauration
pourquoi l'apprentissage vous at il
continué parce que c'est plus facile
pour moi je fais très très scolaire donc
du coup c'est plus pratique je suis pas
tout le temps à l'école jean une
entreprise aussi on travaille en même
temps et ça nous permet d'apprendre plus
que si on était que au lycée ici on est
vraiment en entreprise donc c'est
vraiment du concret ce qu'on fait ici en
cuisine alors que en voie scolaire c'est
pas forcément la même chose ce n'est pas
aussi concret qu'ici
[Musique]
les apprentis des années 40 aux tâches
ingrates c'est fini aujourd'hui la voie
de formation de l'apprentissage a évolué
virginia navetteurs vous êtes
responsable propriétaire de
l'établissement
c'est pourtant une image qui colle à la
peau vous avez du mal à vous en
débarrasser
c'est une image qui colle oui on a
beaucoup de mal à s'en débarrasser alors
qu'aujourd'hui la voie de
l'apprentissage les travaille en cuisine
ou au service a largement évolué nous
sommes plus à l'écouté des apprentis et
nous sommes plus dans un cadre de
formation vous avez des nombreuses
places d'apprentis qui ne sont pas
pourvus dans certains secteurs de votre
établissement
pour quelles raisons selon vous c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de places libres
dans notre milieu
peut-être le secteur c'est difficile
travailler les week-ends et jours fériés
faut demander ça demande beaucoup de
soin faut donner de sa personne pour y
arriver aussi
donc le secteur les horaires le physique
le lieu le lieu aussi c'est pas
forcément facile dans les campagnes de
trouver des apprentis
parce que certains habitats 5 10 km et
les horaires de travail comme on
travaille souvent en coupure enfin on
assure un service du midi et on assurera
le service du soir donc on part deux
heures trois heures pour certains il
faut revenir le soir pour assurer le
service
donc qu'il peut y avoir des problèmes de
transport pour nos jeunes pour venir
travailler pour attirer plus de jeunes
et d'entreprises vers l'apprentissage
le gouvernement lance une opération
séduction aussi appelée loi avenir
professionnel
parmi les mesures phares une aide au
permis de conduire une hausse de la
rémunération
l'âge limite pour devenir apprenti
repoussé à 30 ans le temps de travail
assouplies pour les mineurs et
l'embauchent possible toute l'année
autre changement majeur prévu par la
réforme l'apprentissage est désormais
placée sous la responsabilité des
branches professionnelles et non plus
des régions alors quand la région centre
val de loire investi 92 millions d'euros
l'année dernière
tout de suite ça passe mal gauche et
droite y voit une régression certains
dénoncent la mise en danger de
l'apprentissage l'euro la moindre idée
région au profit des branches
professionnelles est très critique
[Musique]